The most relatable thing about the new Taylor Swift album
is that the two month situationship was more of a stab in the guts
than the six year relationship.
We've all been there, babe.
It makes no sense at all. Yet it makes so much sense. Anyway,
what I really wanna talk about is, um,
this message that I got from Abdul
whose family would like to leave and
they really need your help.
You probably seen this. This family really need to get out.
I just don't understand how there are billionaires
who don't just go through every single one of these links
and top up all the crowd funds.
But there's not clearly, or they would have. Um,
a lot of people sharing this. It's really legit.
The borders are closing really,
really soon.
They're almost halfway there.
So, um,
we just really need to get this over the line.
Please repost this, share this,
donate, do whatever you can.
Um,
just think about what you wanna be able to tell your grandchildren
you were doing at this time.
I put the name of the page down here. Um,
and I put a link in the comments as well.
Um, and yeah,
sending love.